[Musica]
sono nata nel 1998 e nel 2008 quindi
quando avevo 10 anni avevo facebook
non so se vi ricordate com'era facebook
nel 2008
probabilmente molti di voi allora
parlavano di se stessi in terza persona
perché su facebook si usava così però
non vi preoccupate se vi vergognate del
vostro passato sui social
date uno sguardo al mio qui avevo ben
pensato di utilizzare google traduttore
per comunicare i miei 14 amici milanesi
che mi ero tolta l'apparecchio è
divertente ma a volte anche difficile
avere una testimonianza diretta e
precisa di quanto fossimo piccoli
inesperti ingenui nel mio caso non ci
sono soltanto i miei state di facebook a
ricordarmi come rowe
perché quando avevo 14 anni ho
cominciato a caricare video su youtube
quindi per chi non mi conoscesse sono
una youtuber anche se adesso si usa di
più dire web creator un po come david
ellis è passato a collaboratori
scolastici un po come da hostess si è
passato a dire assistenti di volo da
youtubers e passate del web creator
perché youtube ero un po macchiato
dell'onta dell'ignoranza della
superficialità tipo le bionde fatti per
me difficili su due honda youtuber
per cui oltre i miei punti esclamativi a
una testimonianza tridimensionale di
com'ero quando avevo 14 anni
immagino che solo al pensiero risalga un
brivido lungo la schiena
ma non è finita qui perché in realtà
oltre a essere una youtuber web creator
oggi sono anche un influencer un
influencer che ha scritto non uno ma ben
due romanzi quindi nell'ordine youtuber
bionda influencer che ha scritto due
romanzi tutti quelli che non più di 25
anni possono abbandonare la sala non mi
offendo
sono circa 5 anni che convivo con tutti
questi appellativi e
per chi invece decide di rimanere
ritorniamo a gli stati di facebook mi
sono sempre divertita molto a vedere
come i linguaggi virtuali nel senso più
ampio possibile
si costruissero collettivamente nel
corso del tempo
oggi conosciamo la grammatica dei social
sappiamo utilizzarli ci sappiamo muovere
sappiamo quale linguaggio più
appropriato
oggi se qualcuno di voi parlasse di se
stesso in terza persona su facebook
riceverebbe una chiamata di un amico
preoccupato che gli chiede se per caso
una pagina bongiorni stimo caffè non si
è impossessata momentaneamente del suo
profilo visto che sono una delle cause
del declino della società occidentale
a un certo punto ho deciso di auto
analizzarmi e ho scoperto che quattro
anni prima che io nascessi
nel 1994 usciva un libro di pierre le
lim intitolato l'intelligenza collettiva
per un'antropologia del cyberspazio
quando l'ho letto plot twist son che
leggere sono rimasta molto colpita
perché era un testo che teorizzava al
futuro con la digitalizzazione
dell'informazione le relazioni umane
avrebbero smesso di fondarsi solo su
criteri di territorio di potere le
persone avrebbero potuto trovarsi
attorno a poli culturali di interessi
comuni di sensibilità simili a
prescindere dalle distanze dalle
differenze non solo due persone con
delle conoscenze delle competenze
complementari che un tempo non si
sarebbero mai incontrate si sarebbero
finalmente potuto trovare per creare
insieme qualcosa di originale di
collaborativo di innovativo e questa è
l'intelligenza collettiva nel senso
nella sua accezione più ottimista un
intelligenza che unisce le persone che
le spinge a lavorare per una società
insieme per una società migliore una
società dove tutti sono importanti allo
stesso modo tutti sono indispensabili e
dove il sapere è equamente distribuito
ridistribuito a tutti coloro che
partecipano alla costruzione della
collettività 25 anni più tardi
non è andata proprio così internet come
ogni cosa non dotata del libero arbitrio
e al servizio di chi lo usa quindi
internet non è buono internet non è
cattivo internet è internet è soltanto
chi lo utilizza al potere di declinarlo
nei suoi aspetti migliori o peggiori
tutti abbiamo usato male social pure io
lo avete visto delle volte però internet
ha davvero unito delle conoscenze
complementari di fatto stupendoci molto
non so se conoscete la storia di four
chan e del teorema matematico forza né
una piattaforma nata nel 2003 per la
pubblicazione di immagini e che riuniva
community di appassionati di manga
giapponesi è un posto strano nerd dove
gli utenti sono per lo più anonimi e le
conversazioni dopo un po di tempo
scompaiono e su for chan che sono nati i
lince gli uomini esplicitamente misogini
vendicativi ed è sempre su for chan che
oggi si radunano i gruppi altra it negli
stati uniti è un po un posto che ricorda
internet prima di internet le community
forum i nickname l'anonimato bene in
questo strano sottobosco dell'internet
nel settembre del 2011 un utente anonimo
appassionato di manga poneva la seguente
domanda se si volessero guardare tutti i
quattordici gli episodi di una serie tv
manga i cui episodi non sono in ordine
cronologico quanti episodi minimo
bisognerebbe guardare per essere sicuri
di averli visti tutti in tutte le
combinazioni possibili
questa domanda che all'apparenza un
casino
difatti un casino davvero perché si va a
scontrare con i temi delle super
mutazioni limiti superiori inferiori
sono un influencer bionda avevo quattro
matematica non ci sbatte roio la testa
oggi ma ce l'hanno sbattuta per
tantissimo tempo e matematici di tutto
il mondo che cosa è successo che un
utente anonimo di four chan ha risposto
a questa domanda di fatto dimostrando un
teorema matematico mai dimostrato prima
di allora in un angolino buio sperduto
dell'internet e naturalmente i
matematici di tutto il mondo non
sapevano come gestire questa cosa perché
four chan e i forum delle subculture di
internet non sono luogo dove si
dimostrano i teoremi matematici non c'è
credibilità scientifica non c'è
autorevolezza forza non è una rivista
scientifica
eppure ai tempi questa notizia mi aveva
molto stupito un po perché esemplificava
la matassa di pensieri che avevo in
testa e che stava montando in me
a proposito del contesto in cui vivevo e
un po perché ci metteva davanti a ciò
che internet a volte può fare può unirci
può stupirci i può completarsi
io mi sono dimenticata di farvi vedere
la slide da notiziari for chan
andremo avanti c'è altro da dire nel
senso che internet è vero che ci ha
uniti ma è anche vero che ha
completamente rivoluzionato la
distribuzione e la fruizione di
contenuti
io ne sono l'esempio lampante il motivo
per cui qualcuno di voi oggi storce il
naso mentre parlo è che un tempo la
definizione di ciò che era culturalmente
appropriato veniva dall alto in un
processo top down i sacerdoti della
cultura avevano il compito di scegliere
che cosa veniva distribuito e di che
cosa quindi si fruiva con internet
questo modello è completamente cambiato
perché nel momento in cui internet rende
possibile la creazione di contenuti dal
basso quindi rende possibile me non si
tratta più di decidere che cosa
distribuire che cosa no o di definire
cose culture che cosa no dall'alto di
chi la produce
se internet abbattere le barriere
all'ingresso della distribuzione si crea
un mercato enorme pieno di tanti altri
mercati più o meno grandi ed è compito
dello spettatore scegliere di che cosa a
fruire in un contesto enorme disseminato
di contenuti di ogni genere
questo naturalmente crea una frattura
enorme sia economica che umana tra i
sacerdoti della cultura e le persone a
cui la cultura è rivolta
chi sono questi sacerdoti della cultura
questi gatekeeper siete voi sono i
medici prima di twitter sono i
bibliotecari prima di amazon sono
scusate mi si poterebbe catania
iniziati prima di twitter le persone la
cui preparazione è stata davvero messa
in discussione dall'avvento di internet
e dal processo che ha accompagnato
accompagna tutt'oggi la sua nascita e il
suo sviluppo e quindi dalla miriade di
informazioni sconnesse che si trovano in
giro molto spesso scorrette il problema
però è che se l'unica cosa che
continuiamo a fare e alimentare questa
frattura che intercorre tra vecchio e
nuovo tra alto e basso non ne usciamo
più
io mi sentirò sempre una scema e voi
continuerete a sentirvi sempre più messi
da parte
io ho 20 anni e non ho conoscenza
diretta di come fosse il mondo prima di
internet però davvero sono stata
additata più volte come uno degli esempi
di distruzione antropologico e sociale
che internet ha portato con sé questo
tavolo mi ha portato a pensare a quale
potesse essere il mio ruolo come sofia
viscardi a come poter utilizzare tutti
gli appellativi che mi sono stati
affibiati nel corso del tempo e
soprattutto quale potesse essere il
ruolo della mia generazione e di quelle
future all'interno di un contesto così
sconosciuto e nuovo io quando ho
incominciato ad approcciarmi a internet
a youtube ero molto piccola prima era
una spettatrice poi insieme alle mie
amiche abbiamo incominciato a
registrarsi a postare dei video su
youtube e crescendo senza rendermene
conto perché quando si adolescenti non
ci si rende conto che meno dell'ottanta
per cento le cose che si fanno
ho capito di aver assorbito
involontariamente una sorta di
linguaggio virtuale implicito dei
feedback di che cosa funziona di che
cosa no
e mentre mentre io muovevo i miei primi
passi su youtube il mondo attorno a me
così come lo conoscevamo stava cambiando
montava un intolleranza verso le
dottrine verso la conoscenza come
strumento di potere dell'ita rismo
infotainment ed edu tainment perdevano
loro potere in un contesto in cui tutti
potevano dire la loro opinione su un
argomento o addirittura ironicamente la
loro opinione su un argomento come si fa
quindi in un mondo in cui i canali di
divulgazione tradizionali vengono
snobbati è una bella domanda e la
risposta che mi sono data risiede nel
tono di voce
nel contesto storico in cui viviamo
volenti o nolenti la cultura le
informazioni pure e semplici non bastano
più gli esseri umani si sentono soli
si sentono disorientati sono lontani
dalle istituzioni sono sfiduciati nei
confronti di chi un tempo aveva il
compito di accompagnare i più deboli
verso il progresso sociale culturale e
la cosa più difficile come dicevo prima
che stanno e reinventare le regole del
gioco
in questo nuovo contesto sconosciuto
ed è proprio qui ed è proprio una di
queste regole secondo me che dovrebbe
essere il tono di voce
esattamente come preferiamo una persona
empatica che ci indirizza a prendere una
determinata scelta piuttosto che
un'altra
preferiamo la fruizione di contenuti che
siano in tessuti all'interno di una
cornice accogliente vicina
il tono di voce proprio questo è la
trama sulla quale appoggiamo la
costellazione di contenuti culturali che
vorremmo fossero distribuiti e capiti
quindi se la cultura dall'alto oggi
spaventa così tanto sta mesta noi
intraprendere un cammino diverso di
dialogo di parità 6 gatekeeper sono
visti così tanto con sospetto e se il
loro ruolo all'interno dei mezzi di
divulgazione tradizionali il loro ruolo
top down irrita così tanto mette a
disagio
stano e creare un nuovo contesto
all'interno del quale chi detiene il
sapere possa raccontarlo dolcemente a
chi è alla ricerca di informazioni che
poi è quello che il marchio ted sta
facendo da anni ed è proprio il motivo
per cui sono così felice di essere qui
oggi nella divulgazione culturale che
immagino non ci sono giudizi battutine
non ci si sente superiori la cultura non
dovrebbe essere utilizzata come status
ma piuttosto per costruire
silenziosamente una biblioteca di
contenuti informativi e accessibili per
chiunque voglia consultarli e la
costruzione dovrebbe essere collettiva
perché community virtuali e fisiche che
siano hanno bisogno vogliono
nella propria opinione anche sbagliando
all'interno di un cantiere aperto che
mira ad unirci come esseri umani e ad
accompagnarci per mano alla scoperta di
questo nuovo contesto
ed è proprio per questo che per me è
così importante il tono di voce
negli anni ho acquisito esperienza e
visibilità online e naturalmente mi sono
chiesta come poter sfruttare questo
potere responsabilmente bene ed è per
questo che nel mio piccolo insieme a un
prezioso team di coetanei o da poco
lanciato uno spazio virtuale che si
irradia su varie piattaforme proprio
pensato per creare un luogo che possa
accogliere i giovani dove giovani
possano sentirsi meno soli non giudicati
un salotto in cui gatekeeper possano
venire a raccontarci quello che sanno in
una maniera accessibile è proprio su
questo che secondo me noi nativi
digitali dovremmo concentrarci su come
reinventarci il passaggio di
informazioni su come permettere lo
sviluppo culturale all'interno di un
contesto di sfiducia così grande come
questo piuttosto che cercare di decidere
il grado di negatività o di positività
dei social delle persone che li popolano
dovremmo cercare di capire come
utilizzarli per il bene comune e youtube
ei social mi servono proprio per questo
li vorrei utilizzare proprio per questo
per creare un salotto una casa una
piazza all'interno del quale lo scambio
di informazioni sia fluido sia gentile
sia divertente e
per preservare il sapere per rendere
omaggio a levi e al suo giusto ottimismo
e speriamo di riuscirci grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]